yeah what did you think like what was
his best move like yeah I thought Queen
G7 Bishop D4 Queen G5 yeah and then I
thought Queen F4 is uh pretty certain
draw but I didn't know if I uh if I have
anything
particularly uh better so I guess after
Queen F4 you have like some kind of a
perpetual
or sorry oh sorry yeah
oh there are so many things I'm missing
yeah it's complicated oh my God a queen
A5 yeah I missed so okay yeah I should
yeah okay I should count myself pretty
lucky then that um none of these things
happen yeah yeah I was really nervous
today I would say
um at several points but you know
getting a win is obviously great it
takes most of the pressure off for um
tomorrow so I'll uh I'll probably throw
away the game but I'll take the result
for sure